every day this canteen is packed with
students
all coming in here to pick up a hot meal
as the kovid crisis
continues to bite students have been hit
hard by the pandemic many are now
without work
and the means to support themselves
demand for financial help from cruz a
public service
for student life which also runs
services like this canteen
has increased sharply every week around
40 000 meals are being distributed
to students in paris by this
organization meals they can take home
and heat up later
or meals that they can take out now and
eat because
they're hot and ready all at the price
of one euro
now that's been in place since january
as a system to help those students
who are really in need demand is so
high that kus has partnered with other
organizations
in a bid to reach more students in
trouble
we have observed many students turning
towards different types of aid
one of a social services deliveries for
example for buying food
essential things needed in the
supermarket and that is effectively
increasing at an enormous rate
the demand is there it's not just help
with filling their bellies that's needed
many students feel isolated with some 60
saying that they're suffering with
mental health issues
well it's hard to be in your room the
whole day
you're in front of your computer you
don't see anything else than your own
computer and your
small room for first year students they
were not
necessarily able to meet people they
found themselves alone
they don't have the motivation to go to
college they say to themselves
well what am i going to go there for it
is very hard
to to come here to live
alone all by yourself and if you don't
know
anyone who lives in the same house as
you basically you're
alone for well now it's like 11 hours of
the day
often i'm in my room in the evening and
i just start crying
khus has also put in services to assist
those students who
feel alone we do a lot to fight against
isolation
we have put on place student mentors in
every residence who work with us
and who know the residents they go door
to door
make phone calls and take in the new
students it's much more efficient if it
is done by their peers
and not by us because they adapt more
easily they are able to speak freely
they find out if they are not doing well
or if they have difficulties
but we also work with partners for
psychological support for example the
sessions that are prepaid by crews
with a psychologist via teleconsultation
student please for aid have seen many
rally
around them restauranters have been
offering free meals while
in supermarkets shoppers are being asked
to donate an
item towards a solidarity bag but there
is
still a feeling that they have been left
aside by
those in authorities and after a year of
living of the strain
through covid and with still no end in
sight
there are now fears that an entire
generation of students
could be lost charla dubinsky
rt paris
you